[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's great research here showing that
we all catch things out of the corner of
our eye when we are leaving home and
getting on the metro or biking to work
or driving to work or walking to work
you might catch something you might see
something that looks unusual the vast
majority of people dismiss that because
you're in a routine you're going from
work to your office and you're doing
your ordinary life entrepreneurs and
entrepreneurial alert people will jump
on that they will ask a few more
questions they will go for a glitch it's
a little bit of a glitch that you see or
that you catch something is unusual
right if you want to find a gap you need
to probe there
[Music]
it starts with being alert right and in
the financial marketplace we would call
this arbitrage there are financial
arbitrage moments in a marketplace
there's a glitch and if you trade really
quickly in a financial market you can
make a lot of money in the arbitrage
moment right this exists in the
entrepreneurial environment as well so
in an entrepreneurial marketplace if you
can see one of these glitches if you can
spot one of these things or detect an
anomaly and go for it
you can potentially you know harness a
big entrepreneurial outcome so if you
want to spot a gap one thing to do is
see what's working somewhere else and
then ask the questions why is it working
there what's working about that what are
the fundamental underlying principles
that make that work and then fly it over
and reapply it somewhere else
[Music]
an example that we all know is Starbucks
so Howard Schultz did not create coffee
culture he saw it in Italy he went to
this conference in Italy and he loved
the fact that the Italians had left home
and before they got to their conference
or office they stopped in a coffee house
and this was the third place they went
this is the Starbucks third location
argument if home is your first place and
offices your second place the third
place coffee house so he doesn't invent
that he sees it he loves it he picks it
up and he brings it into Seattle and
what very few people know about this is
that he did an exact copy paste so that
does not work in the first Starbucks
example in Seattle they had bowtie clad
waiters and little white porcelain cups
and opera music and a stand-up coffee
bar it looked very Italian and that did
not exactly work in Seattle and so he
did a twist on this model and became
Starbucks that we know now it's more
casual setting you can sit and have your
computer you can talk with others it can
be a workspace for many people it's the
third location but this is the idea that
you see something and you transport it
with a twist
[Music]
there are examples that you can move
across geographies you can move them
across sectors and you can bring old
ideas up to date you can move across
time so Google is an example here where
the founders used PageRank
that was the Stanford library ranking
system of the old school catalogs card
catalogs you apply that old idea to the
world wide web
you get Google and at the time Alta
Vista existed there was other kinds of
search but you could take an old idea
and bring it into the new world of work
and create something really powerful so
this is one way to spot a gap look for
something that works and fly it across
somewhere else and do a little twist on
it this is also called reasoning by
analogy so there's a lot of powerful
research showing that if you compare
contrast if you draw analogies that you
access more of your own brainpower
[Music]
so if your spotting opportunities as an
architect what you're looking for is an
open space and you're looking to build
from the ground up just as an architect
would build a brand-new building in an
open area you want to find a space that
hasn't yet been addressed that often is
a problem right so it's a friction point
it's a bottleneck it's a problem for you
or it's a problem for other people Elon
Musk is a great example so he is in the
world saying and very much building
solutions to solve problems for Humanity
that's exactly what Elon would say and
so Tesla is solving the problem of
sustainable transport and Solar City is
sustainable energy SpaceX is solving the
problem of making life multiplanetary
okay these are huge problems right and
as I've spent time with him in my
research
he literally believes that SpaceX is the
vehicle it's the next step to help
humans take life to other planets so
Mars would be the the planet that he
believes we should inhabit next you know
he is an architect because what he's
doing is building something
piece by piece from the ground up so if
you take SpaceX as an example he went
out to NASA he called he was on the NASA
website he was tracking down scientists
saying hey when is the u.s. space
program going to Mars who's doing that
how come we're not doing that that
problem was not solved there's an open
space then he started calling and
traveling to Russia and saying okay are
you guys doing it if the United States
isn't doing it are the Russians doing it
then he was talking to some people in
China no government was building rockets
that would be going to Mars and so he
stood up SpaceX and he said all right
we'll do a private company and we will
build a reusable rocket this is a
different way from reasoning by analogy
that's the Sunbird in the
architect idea you reason by first
principles which means you break things
down to the fundamental elements the
basic axioms of many math Matt
mathematicians and physicists reason
this way Ilan is originally trained as a
physicist you figure out the fundamental
truths and the elements and then you
build piece by piece from the ground up
so with SpaceX that's what he's done the
SpaceX team has taken over the contracts
to resupply the International Space
Station SpaceX is doing that at 1/10 the
price the NASA did so this is solving a
problem that wasn't solved and building
something with the elements in a
different way from the ground up the
integrator is a person that looks at
putting things together that haven't
been put together before in the past and
you're mashing and smashing concepts
together sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't and then sometimes it creates
extraordinary opportunity so if you
think about the idea that in the past a
luxury car was one thing and an
all-terrain vehicle was something
completely different you put those
together and you get luxury SUV this is
a huge category that all the different
manufacturers of automobiles are making
now that's an example of being an
integrator putting those two things
together
and creating a new category Chipotle is
a prime example so Steve ELLs is a
classically trained chef he's an art
history major originally he's not even a
business person and what he realizes is
while he has complete disdain for fast
food and he really does he is trained at
the New York Culinary Academy if you are
a culinary artist as a chef you cannot
stand the idea that any hamburger place
is got a frozen patty reheating on a
grill and packaged up in a little
plastic package and handing off to
people the traditional fast-food model
so what Steve ELLs does is creates fast
casual dining and Chipotle is
revolutionary in this mod
we see many examples like it now but
it's cooking for the line so as people
line up in a Chipotle there is slicing
and dicing and cooking a food right in
front of you as the line gets longer
more cooking goes on as the line gets
shorter less cooking goes on and that is
the intersection of fast food and casual
dining so all of us can go into the
world and look for things to combine
many of the internet models are this as
well many of the online retail sites
discounted luxury goods in an auction
format for example
oh there's different things all brought
together creating some very large
internet retailing models now so that's
the idea of being an integrator it's
just mashing and smashing things
together and creating novelty at those
intersections curiosity is what really
unlocks the ability to spot opportunity
and it's important and available to
every single one of us to continue to
ask questions and to continue to believe
that we can discover and probe and learn
more and more every single day the
Achilles heel here for many business
people is that you believe you're an
expert so anyone who's already believing
that they have a certain expertise in
any variety of business or any part of
life actually stops asking questions and
that's a dangerous thing so if you want
a spot opportunity and you want to
create something new in the world if you
want to keep up in a rapidly changing
world
curiosity is your friend curiosity is a
tool to be alert and to be able to see
things that other people don't see
[Music]